[Music]
millions of dollars in narcotics seized
in a major bust involving nevada state
police victoria saha has been covering
this story joining us now with more
information victoria
brian we're talking about more than 11
million dollars worth of drugs found
over seven days along the 15 as numerous
law enforcement agencies work to get
these drugs off our streets from may 6
to the 12th police say there were 219
traffic stops and 57 vehicles that were
searched leading law enforcement to find
2 100 pounds of narcotics including
marijuana fentanyl and cocaine this all
happened on the 15th through the moapa
river indian reservation nevada state
police say they found 72 large bags of
marijuana in a rental truck that was
pulled over two suspects were arrested
and charged with trafficking authorities
say this was the largest illegal
marijuana seizure by the nevada state
police back in february there was
another drug bust operation in the same
area in that incident police found 2.8
million dollars worth of narcotics